I first met Thiel at a 100 mile run in
San Diego and I was running I was
running this race as part of a
six-person relay team with friends and
he was running the entire race by
himself
and the run was unsupported so you have
to bring your own supplies so we had you
know we overdid it a little bit we had a
tent and we had masseuses and food I
mean we were ready for like in case we
had to stay there a week and he had a
folding chair a bottle of water and a
bag of crackers and I just thought to
myself like who is this guy never seen
anything like it
and during the race I kept an eye on him
and around mile 70 he weighed probably
260 pounds which is quite large for an
ultra runner he had broken all the small
bones in both of his feet and a kidney
damage and he finished the race so when
it was done I googled um he had a
fascinating life story and I decided
literally to cold-call him and I flew
out and met with them and after sitting
with him for a couple of minutes I
realized that I could learn so much from
a guy like this and what makes him tick
and various buckets in my life would be
so much better if a little bit of what
he had rubbed off on me I asked him to
come live with my family and I for a
month so at the time that I invited CEO
to come live with us I had a 18 month
old son I was married still am two more
kids since and I had sold a couple of
businesses I was in a great place
professionally in my life but I was also
in a routine and routines are great but
they can also be a rut and I found that
I just wasn't getting better I was doing
the same thing every day
like so many of us wake up go to work
come home you know have dinner repeat
and I just wanted to get off order pilot
and I thought that he would be a great
way to get in good shape but also to
just mix up my routine and and get
better the first day that seal came to
live with me he asked me to do he said
how many pull-ups can you do and I'm not
great at pull-ups I did about eight just
getting over the bar eight and then
sorry take 30 seconds and do it again so
30 seconds later I got up on the bar I
did 6 struggling
and said all right one more time we
waited 30 seconds and I barely got three
or four and I was done I mean couldn't
move my arms done and he said all right
we're not leaving here until you do a
hundred more and I thought there's no
we're going to be here for quite a long
time because there's no way that I could
do 100 but I ended up doing it one at a
time and he showed me prove to me right
there that you know there was so much
more we're all capable of so much more
than we think we are and it was just a
great lesson it was actually the first
thing that we did it was just a great
lesson in we had so much more in our
reserve tank than we think we do one of
the things that seal said to me and it's
in in the book and one thing that people
have said that really resonated with
them he would say that when you're when
your mind is telling you you're done
you're really only 40 percent done and
he had a motto if it doesn't suck we
don't do it and that was his way of
everyday forcing us to get uncomfortable
to figure out what our baseline was and
and what our you know what our comfort
level was and just you know turning it
upside down the 40% rule maybe it's give
or take a little but look at a marathon
most people hit the wall at a marathon
at Mile anywhere from 16 to 20 and you
know 99% of the people in this country
that run marathons finish and they all
predominantly all of them go through
this hit the wall so where does that
extra 50 or 60 percent or whatever the
numbers come from I mean it's their
brain saying I'm done I don't want to
continue but there will saying you know
what let me get to the finish line so we
all have that will it's just a matter of
how do we apply it to not just with the
once-a-year marathon but to our daily
lives and make it you know apply to a
variety of things
you